Hello world! Shawn Grooms here again with Free Code Camp and in this video I'll be
explaining what sets are. A set is a
collection of distinct objects called
elements or members. An element is
essentially anything you want it to be
and for example elements could be
numbers, letters, variables, more sets, or
nothing at all. Sets are usually denoted
by capital letters such as capital A
capital B, C, E, or F and we say that the
set contains elements. For example, we
could say that the set A equals the set
containing the element 5 or we can say
that 5 is an element of A. Now, I will be
inttoducing a lot of symbols like this
this just means is an element of and
it'll save us a lot of time in future
videos and I don't have to write out is
an element of each time so that will
come in handy. So, what does the set
actually look like?
Well, there are two common types of
for sets and the one
I'm interested in this video is roster
notation and it looks like this: it's just
curly braces with elements inside
separated by commas, which is very
similar to JavaScript - the only
difference being that in math we use
curly braces and in JavaScript we use a
square bracket. So, now let's just walk
through these. So, the set A
equals the set containing the element 5
- that's how you would read this. The set B
equals the set containing the elements 2, 3,
and 4. The set C equals the set
containing elements d, f, and g. Now, d, f, and g, they're
not - they don't have to be variables.
They're either variables or they could
be characters - it just depends on the
context. The set E contains no
elements in this case which has an
impact that you'll see in future videos.
Finally, the set F equals the set
containing elements A, B and C. In this case,
our elements are sets so we would read
this as F equals the set containing the
set containing the element 5, the set
containing elements 2, 3, and 4,
and the set containing d, f, and g. So, in the next video i'll be going over a
different form of set notation in
addition to introducing you to some
common sets and this will set us up
eventually my goal is to bring us up to
being able to define and understand
algorithms and this is where we have to
begin.